in the last video we factored this
polynomial in order to find the real
roots we factored it by grouping which
essentially doing the distributive
property in reverse twice and i
mentioned that there's two ways you
could do it you could actually from the
get go add these two middle degree terms
and then think about it
and then think about it from there and
so what i thought i would do is just a
quick video on on that alternative so if
we add
instead of grouping if we add these
middle two terms actually i'll just
factor i'll just focus on the fourth
degree polynomial here we know that we
have an x out front this fourth degree
polynomial
this fourth degree polynomial
is going to simplify to
x to the fourth plus 7 x squared
plus 7
x squared minus 18
minus
18.
and now if we want to factor this we
could recognize a pattern here
so you probably remember or hopefully
you remember if you don't then you might
want to review your factoring
polynomials but if you have x plus a
times x plus b that's going to be equal
to
x
is going to be equal to x squared plus
the sum of those two numbers a and b as
being the coefficient on the x term plus
the product of those two numbers and if
you just if you just multiply this out
this is what you would get but if this
was x squared plus a times x squared
plus b instead of this being x squared
this would be x to the fourth instead of
this being x this would be x squared
which is exactly the pattern we have
here so what two a's and b's that if i
add them up i would get 7
and if i were to take their product i
get
i get
negative 18. well since their product is
negative we know that they are of
different signs one will be positive one
will be negative and since their sum is
positive we know that the larger of the
two numbers is going to be positive
and so what jumps out at me is 9 times
negative 2. you multiply those you get
negative 18 you take their sum you get
7. and so we can rewrite this just
looking at this pattern here as x
squared
plus 9
times x squared
minus 2. i could say plus negative with
the same thing as x squared minus 2. and
then that's exactly what we got right
right over here and of course you have
this x out front that i didn't consider
right over here and then this as we did
in the previous video you can recognize
as a difference of squares and then
factor it further to actually find the
roots but i just wanted to show you that
you could solve this by by by regrouping
or you can solve this by just i guess
you could say more traditional factoring
means and notice this 9 and negative 2
this is what was already broken up for
us so that we could factor by
regrouping